[Music]
we're thrilled to have you with us for
the next 45 minutes or so to talk about
Google's service compute options which
you can all use today and some you'll be
able to use in the near future my name
is Alexei and my name is Guillaume and
we will cover cloud functions App Engine
with all the new exciting features some
of you have heard of already maybe that
we're announced yesterday as well as in
this morning's keynote we will also
highlight a multi-service demo spanning
across multiple products multiple
languages and finally we will have a
glimpse at the future of service
containers now let's get started but
first what is important for your company
what do you do as a developer for a
company well hopefully you build you
create applications and functionality
that matters to your users and to do
that if you were to deploy your
application on your own infrastructure
you would have to deal with a number of
things such as selecting that
infrastructure buying the hardware
potentially configuring the operating
system deciding whether you are going to
use containers or not defining what kind
of storage strategy you have and so
forth
configuring the network the load
balancing the load the logging and all
of these things so building a pipeline
of continuous integration is maybe
something else you need to take care of
and on top of that the company needs to
worry about security patches maintaining
everything in in good shape and all of
these operational tasks are very
important things and you need to do all
of these before you can start writing
any code so let me introduce you to
Google's new server list data center no
obviously this is you all know this the
joke never gets old but serverless does
involve service actually lots of servers
besides this is a really old building
way too dirty for to be a data center
the key here though is that as
developer you do not need to manage the
service you do not need to install OS
updates patches you do not need to set
up monitoring out of scaling or
configure any kind of load balancing we
offer to do it for you so here's our a
little attempt to define service in two
different ways the first one is really
an operational model and I think most
people here from familiar with that you
don't manage the servers you don't even
see them you don't see the abstraction
of a server you're higher up the stack
the other aspect of that is of course
that it Auto scales if you have traffic
we will make sure we have enough
resources to serve that traffic and of
course we will have the ability to scale
from 0 to almost infinity and we will
bill you for that that is also part of
the deal so you will pay for the usage
no usage no bill that's the other part
now second we believe it's also a
programming paradigm one would say a
cloud in the native way of developing
applications instead of shipping code
that bundles a lot of libraries as part
of the application instead you consume
services that are otherwise exposed as
such and you do expose maybe yourself a
few functionalities as services so
instead of having a very tightly coupled
intertwined set of features your
application has services and maybe this
is event-driven and rather than having
synchronous calls between services yours
able to take in asynchronous
event-driven calls now server this as
you can see is way more than just
functions bits of code running in the
cloud it can be computes we'll
definitely talk about that today but it
spans across many other things such as
databases where you did not see the
concept of a server all you want is a
persistent service that's
really all you really need data
warehousing analytics data processing an
ETL or even machine learning training
that can be done without having to setup
any sort of cluster and in and of course
without having to resize or manage those
clusters so compute on its own is not
enough you need all of those but let's
focus on compute for for a moment serval
is said on GCP of course you can map all
of these things to lots of different
products that we have but we'll focus on
tile functions and App Engine which are
the two products that we have both of
them are generally available as well
you'll see in a moment but we will focus
on those while using some of the other
services we will be using cloud pub/sub
a highly scalable messaging system that
can be used to build some really
scalable applications we will use cloud
datastore we will not use bigquery
although this is an amazing product
which basically takes your data and your
queries and returns insights results to
your SQL queries in interactive time and
without having to understand how this is
all deployed so again we're in the
service realm but let's go back to
compute cloud functions and App Engine
so cloud functions is functions as a
service if you are into acronyms and app
engine is platform as a service for for
those old enough to remember that
acronym so why - why have two products
well let's find out the great things
about choice is that it natively Bulls
you to adapt to different requirements
that you might have but the other side
of it is of course that you need to
understand what kind of choice you're
making and what the drawbacks might be
so let's take a moment and review both
products as they're available to you
today so let's probably start with
functions and qiyam thank you all right
so more and more our applications are in
structure is becoming more and more even
driven so we're interested in events
that are being emitted by some kind of
service application API it's a tram that
are intercepted here in our case by
cloud functions which is going to
respond to events inside our function we
can also trigger new events or invoke
other services API is store some data in
in cloud datastore file in cloud storage
etc the unit of work for cloud functions
is as the name implies a function so
function it's a small unit of work with
a fine-grained small focus there are two
triggers to way to trigger your function
so either synchronous calls with HTTP or
just a mere HTTP or get or post or etc
or more a synchronous events so for
example a new file stored in cloud
storage or a new message on a pub sub
topic which can trigger your your
function some examples of where you can
use functions so typically one example
I'm going to take with the HTTP call
that's if you're building a chat bot for
example with dialogue flow for the the
Google assistant you can define a web
hook within the the dialogue flow UI to
say okay when there's some need for
business logic for fetching some data or
something from the the chat bot then
call this function similarly if you're
using github for your source code
there's commit hooks which allow you to
be notified when there's a new pull
request when there's a new coming commit
coming up in your source tree so that's
for the synchronous calls with HTTP but
another example that's what we're also
going to use in the demo later on for
example with pictures
being uploaded to a cloud storage so you
want to create thumbnails you want to
you know crop the picture or do
something with that picture once it's
stored in storage your function is
notified it is triggered in the in the
demo as you shall see we're going to use
the new newly announced cloud scheduler
so whenever at regular intervals of time
let's say in my case I'm using a cloud
scheduler for triggering an event every
one minute every minute so I'm going to
get a little message so there are
different ways of using the cloud
scheduler but in my case I'm going to
use the pub/sub mechanism of time to get
the the message to trigger one of my
functions and all that obviously well
yeah another example that was
interesting that was given yesterday I
think by orientation that was for
example with stackdriver you can create
alerts when something happens for
example you can see by looking through
the logs that something happens that is
unusual
you could also specify that the alert
pings your function so that's an
interesting use case for further
automating your your infrastructure your
your whole project so from a developer
perspective sorry from a developer
perspective what you deploy is really
just code basically so as a developer
you just focus and who's a developer in
the audience yeah quite a few hands nice
so if you're a developer you focus on
your code and you don't necessarily want
up front in particular - you have to
think about servers but creating
clusters about managing the servers or
the provisioning or all that stuff also
now at some point if your application
it's very successful you're going to
need to be able to you know scale and
well it's not always easy to scale your
your architecture to cope with incoming
traffic and traffic spikes but also a
nice aspect of server less it's
auto-scaling down so from zero to n
that's nice but also from n back to one
or zero that's also something that's
important to do and of course you don't
want to pay for nothing basically so if
your code is not running you're not
going to be built so that's yeah pay
only for what you use right from your
functions so I mentioned the few
triggers you know cloud storage but et
cetera but from your functions you can
call all the services you want so you
have at your disposal
things like various kind of databases
datastore spanner a big table etc you
have access to all the machine learning
api's that's what we're going to do with
the demo with the vision API you take
advantage of all the logging
capabilities error reporting of
stackdriver so it's a 1 how to say that
a big bag of things that you can take
advantage of within the code of your
functions so as you learned about
yesterday
cloud functions is generally available
with a 99.5 person's service level
agreement it's also available across
different regions for regions two in the
u.s. one in Europe one in Asia
what's interesting to know as well is
that your functions they don't have to
be all be in one and single region but
you can have functions in Europe
functions in the USA within the same GCP
project so if you want to have functions
that are closer to your users you can't
you can do that you have modern runtimes
so the newly announced runtimes node 8
for using things like a single weight to
make your your code easier to read when
handling promises etc Python 3.7 so that
it's the very latest and greatest Python
with a thin flask
framework for defining your functions
and there are also more languages coming
soon in terms of the common features
already mentioned the all the error
reporting login capabilities which is
always nice when you're developing
debugging and if you have got some you
know prediction issues you want to trace
back what actually happened a very
important aspect that's the build and
dependency resolution in the cloud so
you don't have to for example when you
use node modules some may require some
libraries or need to be a compile
because there there's some some native
code so you don't have to cross compile
things locally upload the modules and
things like that is really in the cloud
that this dependency resolution and
build is being done so it's one thing
less to think about religious focus on
defining your dependencies and writing
your code I think there was something
else yeah oh yeah the when I was
mentioning dependencies the we your
functions are actually running on an
Ubuntu image under the hood and there
are several libraries that are already
pre-installed so for example things like
ffmpeg for dealing with videos image
magic if you want to you know do some
stuff with your pictures but you also
have all the set of libraries that are
required to run Chrome in headless mode
for example if you want to have a
function that takes screenshots or
generates PDFs from a particular web
page if you want to do some kind of
end-to-end testing where you your
function actually controls a browser
from headless browser you can do that
easily with clad functions today all
right so the newest capabilities that
have been announced as well that's VP
seen VPN access so you can say when you
deploy your function that your function
is tied to a particular VPN network so
with that what that means is that let's
say you already have some VMs running on
compute engine your function is able to
access those
vm's and chat with those VMs so it's not
two separate worlds anymore in addition
to that related to security you have
also I am role binding so if you want to
say ok this function should be called
only by that role or et cetera this is
now possible so instead of having a
function that is publicly available on
the cloud via HTTP for example you have
finer grained control now in terms of
secure access we also introduced scaling
controls so it's especially for limiting
actually the number of instances of one
particular function so this can be
useful for things like cost control of
course but also let's say you have a
function that calls a database and
instead of overloading the database with
too many connections if you know you
cannot have I'd say more than 100
connections you can say ok I don't want
more than 100 functions to be running to
avoid the problem of you know training
the the connections and heavy
connections issue with your database
before before it was GA well no well it
is already GA but it's not yet so all
these stuff except the environment
variables which are already available
but this stuff is coming till the end of
the year so what I wanted to say about
the classical Direct Connect is that so
far and as of today you had to go
through the internet if you need to
access a classical instance but now with
the upcoming direct sequel the Direct
Connect Cloud sequel oh I I mix the
words you get at you are able to go
through the Google Network directly
without going outside through the
internet to get access to your database
last but not least environment variables
so with functions you are able to define
your environment variables for example
if you want to define different kind of
environment you know prod dev staging or
if you have some any pieces of
configuration that shouldn't
be stored in your source code in your
source tree in your repository can be
passed as environment variables and
we'll see an example in in the demo
where I'm actually using environment
variables alright that's about it for
functions let's see a bit more about App
Engine yep let's let's switch gears and
talk about App Engine actually no the
demo will come just a little bit later
can we go back to slides so the
fundamental difference with cloud
functions here is well in the name the
unit of computing of deployment if you
will here is an app so an app obviously
is coarser grained than a function it
might be interesting if you're moving
from a monolith to the cloud I mean
moving from a monolith to function based
programming and full micro-services
might be a bridge too far for many
people instead app engine may be a
better fit and still in the realm of
service where we take care of a lot of
things for you as we already said but as
we will see you are still in App Engine
able to structure your code and and and
that we believe is important so the unit
is the application the trigger is HTTP
and it's best used for migrating we
believe existing applications and
generally speaking for HTTP services
most developers will have preferred
languages I know I do and expect to use
them with no constraints like don't tell
me to use that proprietary API don't
tell me you cannot use that set of
libraries I would like to be able to use
this in what we call idiomatic ways
which is any habit that I have I would
like to be able to take this to the clap
we'll come back to this this is a really
important to deploy your application
there's really no configuration needed
it's a G cloud our SDK command line app
deploy and it will look at your
artifacts your application and it will
deploy this and once deployed similar as
with functions you'll be able to auto
scale from zero to
a lot and back to zero billing is done
accordingly no traffic no cost so App
Engine today App Engine is 10 years old
so that's that's a decade of a lot of
things and some of you might have seen
app and jet not evolved quite a bit for
the last few years and the reason for
that is that the team has been hard at
work on a new infrastructure and a new
sandbox technology which enables a lot
of things security being the most
important but for you developers there
are a few things coming with that as
well
so first of all we have generally
available the Java 8 runtime which
enables not only Java 8 and and all the
features that come with it it's just you
know lambda expressions pipeline streams
but also all the languages running on
the JVM such as Scala Coughlin groovy so
that is really something that a lot of
people use the second thing is just as
with functions we support node 8
currently in beta in the next 30 days
you will have access to Python and PHP
with very modern and recent versions as
well and more features more languages
more updates are coming soon we also
have a new instance scheduler that logic
that says how many and how quickly and
how often I need to spin up new
instances and how what is the logic
behind scaling down which is really I
would think the secret sauce before
behind app engine is new and and that
was released a couple of months ago we
believe it's more predictable so you
understand why it's doing the things
it's doing
it offers better utilization with less
cold start so when you hit an instance
that is hit for the first time or this
less of that and it offers new settings
to balance cost versus performance and
we believe we have faster deployments
which is always important we do a lot of
things when we deploy we're deploying
across a cluster I mean the cluster is
there you just don't see it so we need
to do a lot of
checks because before we can say that
the app is is live and running and we
believe we can do that better and if
you're in the healthcare industry you'll
be happy to note that as of again a few
months ago we are now HIPAA compliant
now let's go back to this idiomatic way
of developing apps we call this the
second-generation idiomatic runtimes and
this is enabled by technology called G
visor anybody who's heard of G visor
here before just a few people this is
really cool technology you don't have to
really understand how it works you can
just rip the benefits it is an open
source technology that we've announced
at the last cube con so a few months ago
it is a new sandbox technology which
offers this idiomatic developer
experience you can use any API any
library that you want and it should just
work any module from the official no GS
package manager' such as headless Chrome
which Gil mentioned any Java jar library
any Python library you do not need to
change your code in the way it uses
those libraries at most you should have
to add maybe some metadata to your
application in the form of samyama or
XML just to describe it to give it a
version number and that's really it note
by the way that everything I'm
describing here all the benefits of G
visor is something we're using both in
cloud functions and in App Engine now
this is not a new feature but I think
it's important we spend a minute on it
App Engine because application can have
multiple distinct layers or modules say
front-end some business logic some data
access layer some admin pieces you'll
see in the demo it's interesting to be
able to split your application in
different modules or services in App
Engine you can do that of course each
service has a version potentially all
those versions by the way are active at
the same time and you'll see why that
could be useful and each version can be
scaled independent
from the other one you probably don't
have this game skilling needs for some
admin back-end with two people accessing
it and the front end which is for the
world to use so we believe it's a great
fit for micro services each service can
also be written in a different language
there's really no constraints there and
if that makes sense for you you can
certainly take advantage of that
but maybe more powerful this built-in
feature multiple services active at the
same time enables things such as service
level upgrades a be testing cannery
releases all of that was something we
call traffic splitting traffic splitting
is not a new feature either but it
proves to be extremely powerful and and
and I would say trivial or very easy to
enable once you've given a module a
service a name which is freeform
you could call it one two three five you
could call it beta a green red blue
whatever you'd like you do this in a
config file once you have that you can
start addressing and and sending parts
of the traffic to a new version that
enables for you and this is based on IP
address on cookie or completely at
random so this allows you to do
something like a be testing maybe you
will be offering shipping cost to fifty
percent of your users or you'll be
offering an general discount on your
goods to the other fifty percent you'll
see which one works best so that's
that's something you can do and of
course you can also do cannery releases
deploy your new app to a few percentage
of your users see how it behaves and as
you increase confidence and you see no
errors you say start sending more load
more traffic and eventually you move the
entire traffic to it or you go back
because you've found something that's
really bad and no code changes no config
changes in terms of changing any XML or
llamó file this is all done very simply
from the command line or from the UI and
of course traces and logs
be used to filter by version and this is
where you can see that something's going
good or not so good and you might need
to rollback so though those of you that
have been using App Engine for several
years you might have seen that a number
of App Engine specific features I have
graduated into a standalone product the
most famous of them has been datastore
which might seem crazy but back in the
days you had to use App Engine to access
this amazing new SQL back-end that we
have there are many more services that
we'd like to point out but there's two
that we'd like to point out they're
fairly new and that can be used from App
Engine from cloud functions or maybe
even if you're you know still running on
a VM on compute engine that you can use
and that are now standalone GCP product
the first one is called cloud tasks
which will soon be in beta I think the
official thing is in the next 30 days so
stay tuned yeah initially this was an
App Engine feature task queues and and
it's coming soon as a standalone and
fully managed service it will take care
of executing dispatching and delivering
a large number of distributed tasks
using this you can perform work
asynchronously outside of the user
requests and process you know requests
in batches so this is a great way to
scale your architecture the main
architectural benefit here is really to
be able to decouple the the user request
from scaling all those micro services
and the beta release you'll have support
for Python Java and node and you'll be
able to set things such as rate limits
retry configs and this will be I believe
something that's very useful for
building scalable microservices
architectures next is Google Cloud
scheduler well this is really Kron in
the cloud nothing super fancy but this
is something that a lot of people need
and and we believe that what we have now
with cloud scheduler which we'll show
briefly in the demo is the ability to
regularly scheduled tasks and and have
them operate at those regular intervals
so common use cases are being able to
send an email report on a daily basis
maybe update some cache data every 10
minutes or update some summary
information every hour this is also
probably the most elegant solution to
the frequently requested feature of
invoking functions on a at regular
intervals so again this is not tied to a
product this is a product its own and
can be used to to trigger jobs and
manage all of them in one place rather
than have and reinvent this cron feature
in different parts of your architecture
and of course you can hit HTTP endpoints
pops up topics or relative URL handlers
to hit App Engine apps and this will be
made available in the next 30 days
now before I hand it over to Guillaume
for the demo we will be walking through
some slides to explain what we built
with all the technology that we've just
discussed and hopefully this will be
interesting to you over to you Jim thank
you so I decided to create a little
picture sharing application so if you
want to try it you can go to pick daily
appspot.com so with this application you
can take pictures of stuff around you so
you can feel free to do a create a
picture right away
selfies whatever as you can see there's
the picture there's a little color
around it that's a main color of the
dominant color of the picture we'll see
why this is important later on we also
see tags this is actually what the
vision API tells me okay in that picture
I see I don't know
was it interior cushion furniture bed
etcetera and so if you click on the pink
camera button you can do we I'll do it
later on I'll take a picture of myself
on stage so you can choose the camera
you want and after that there's also the
little tags icon in the menu and the
icons on the top you can also have a
look at the most frequent tags most
frequent labels that have been
recognized and so that's the first app
engine service and I also have another
service which is the our admin back-end
basically just for Alex and myself to
see so you can see two tabs published
and filtered because with the vision API
I'm checking that nobody uploaded
something weird and I can publish and
publish stuff so this is the the main
ideas in that in that little demo so
what's happening so a user takes a
picture the the picture of via the the
web page by a JavaScript the picture is
sent to the main app engine service the
the front end which defines a Web API
where I can post my picture when that
picture is taken and sent to my app the
we are going to store that picture in
cloud storage when this happens oh yeah
the cloud storage and before I mention
what happens to the picture we also add
some metadata like the the URL basically
or the name of the picture in data store
when that picture arrives on cloud
storage function is triggered this
function is going to call the vision API
to get labels so that's the tags you see
build the pictures to get the color the
dominant color that's why the Yi the
pictures were framed with
some colors and we're also using the the
filter the Save Search annotation which
tells you if the content contains you
know adult racy violence medical content
and that kind of stuff when the vision
API answers the request the function
actually adds metadata in the data store
so again the labels color filters etc in
the entry we created when we uploaded
the picture so that's one thing when at
so the if you remember the the popular
tags page in the popular tags so the way
I implemented it it was a bit of an
afterthought but I'm actually going
through all the metadata stored in data
store so I'm going through all the all
the lines in my data store so it's not
the most efficient way to do that so
it's an expensive query which takes time
to run actually for the few hundreds or
thousands of pictures that I have it's
pretty fast but let's imagine I've got
millions of pictures and if I have to go
through all those pictures the query
might take a little bit more time so
instead what I'm doing is that that I'm
taking actually a snapshot of the most
frequent pictures that I'm storing again
in datastore so that way I don't have to
do the the costly operation I just have
to do a read a simple read operation in
the data store rather than going through
all the all the results so App Engine
for the front-end two functions in no
js' and we have a second service in App
Engine which is the admin interface all
right so let's see that on the demo
machine so as everybody knows the
internet has been invented for sharing
pictures and videos of cats so let me
introduce you to Phuket she's called and
it's a one month and a half old
little baby cat a little kitty so here
I'm looking at the cat tag so I have a
few yeah I love my cat so I have a few
pictures of my time cat all right
you can see the the latest pictures yeah
thank you for uploading some picture
yeah that's cool
thanks thanks a lot for that I can also
take one Alex Eakin okay so that was the
yeah the the new picture button and here
you cannot see the the tags or the most
frequent tags I don't know which one I
could have a look at like flowers there
are a few flowers that have been
uploaded from well that's from my garden
Oh your tennis racquet somewhere I think
it's in recreation or fun pounds I don't
remember where it is no fun yeah okay
that's cool oh yeah oh we were very
serious earlier alright so yeah that's
that's how a quick introduction to this
to this application so thanks for
sharing your own pictures and feel free
to add additional pictures later on oh
yeah I need to show you the admin
interface as well so here
oh there shouldn't be where is it
there's there are some broken links
that's strange interestingly some of
your pictures have been filtered spoof
okay this one is racy I don't know why
or like this one it almost looks like
blood so there's violence but it's
actually my dessert I'm sorry that's not
blood anyway so sometimes you know the
vision API it could be blood but it's
just some strawberry or something some
jam so let's have a look at how this has
been implemented right so here I'm going
to show you first I'll start with the
the Java app which is the the main app
that that you are using so I used a
small framework called spark Java and
which is a very lightweight framework so
that's nice for App Engine I have a few
routes so so this is the you know the
the route of the
the website I have tagged so for example
when I was navigating via tags like I
don't know black font whatever so you
can see in the the URL tags slash black
so this is tags clone tag there's a pad
part I could have created in all the
service for that one actually the the
the pure API part which is not for the
visual web front-end but which is used
by the admin API as well as by the so
it's a view jazz JavaScript application
which calls this API API part so there's
a post request here for example the - so
/ API / pictures when you post there you
can post the the picture so when I'm
doing that you can see that I'm creating
a new entry in the data store that's
where I'm going to store the metadata
for my picture and I'm also using the
cloud storage creating a getting the the
bucket and adding a new file in my
bucket and then I written some some JSON
content perhaps I can show you one more
so like this one that's the one which
gets the all the other pictures
basically so I've got a query I go over
the the picture kind
I ordered by you know the most recent
pictures I just want to see the top 20
and then I'm returning so I didn't fully
implement pagination but I was using the
the cursor to be able to do pagination
but that's for the next version of my
start of picture sharing you know and
then I'm rich and I'm returning the the
JSON payload things to the jeezum
library so this is the basically what
the the API and front-end code looks
like there's the perhaps in the
resources for example I could also show
you like this one that's the the view GS
code which actually calls thanks to the
fetch API which calls my back-end so /ap
ice has pictures potentially with the
tag and then the JavaScript code updates
the page single page app style to show
the pictures especially when I navigate
from text to tanks so that's the main
app here now let's have a quick look at
the the admin service so the admin
service so initially I was when I wanted
to you know tweak the the metadata or
delete a picture or unpublish or publish
a particular picture I was going through
the the the cloud console and go through
the console just to do my little updates
better as I was a bit in a rush
one of our colleagues Valentin was a go
developers on the a by the way I can do
a little admin API admin front-end for
you if you want so you create a go
application a go App Engine application
with some jQuery and I styled it in the
the same style of the rest of the
application and so you can see the
published picture and it's interesting
because there's a bed that wasn't there
this morning I don't know why and as you
could see I can you know zoom in you can
see the reasons why something was
filtered and I can potentially delete so
for example I don't know I can delete
this one well you get the idea so this
one pictures dot go so that's my second
module there are a few routes that have
been defined to get the pictures do the
filtering deleting pictures there's a
stretch to define the structure of the
data that's in the data store creating
mmm keys for the data store and let's
have a look let's say at the list of
pictures so again we're doing a query on
all the pictures defining some order
filtered processed times buys time
stamps etc so it's just some plain go
code and as you remember when you see
here all the little tags they are
actually coming from the vision API so
when the picture is uploading on clouds
rage I'm triggering the function that
I'm going to show you right now so we
saw some Java we saw something go so now
let's have a look at some JavaScript
with node so here I'm receiving an event
the event is actually the in terms of
the data that's stored in that event
object
it contains the the file name of the
picture and the bucket in which this
picture is stored so what I'm doing
there is that I'm going to prepare a
query for the vision API so label
detection I want the image properties to
be able to get the dominant color safe
search for filtering I'm calling the API
here once I get the API I go the the the
call is successful I get through the the
JSON to find the right information and
then I'm going to store the some update
to the metadata follow for the file so
I'm going to store the main call other
labels etc back into the data store yes
and the other one so as I said computing
the most frequent tags is a an expensive
operation so I decided to do some
snapshots once every minute so I used I
defined a crumb of well once every
minute please call my function so this
is the second function which is here so
first of all notice that I used the new
feature environment variables here so I
can access the environment variable by
using process dot n dot the name of my
environment variable so I have a default
value just in case it's not passed as
parameters but if you look at the
functions here in the console popular
tags which is here you can see down
there up environment point I define the
URL of the end point all right
what am I doing here so I'm not really
interested in any data from the events
because it's really just you know one at
once every minute so I there's no data
that I actually need and then I'm doing
the frequency calculation and storing
the the most freakin tax in the in the
data store again so that's about it for
the code so again you see so they were
why previously there were some errors
when I was developing those functions
you can see the actual usage there so
there are really two functions popular
tags which is a message via a topic
cloud scheduler pushes a message on the
club sub and here there's a there's a
bucket that's the bucket where I stole
my pictures and I'd like to show you two
things so this morning I did load so it
was yeah this morning so it's a bit
small but if you remember in the
abstract we said a scale from 0 to 1000
so I did I created some load injectors
to be able to try to go up to a 1000 so
I can't zoom in because it's gone but I
managed to go up to 938 instances
created in just a couple of minutes
by adding more load and more load
injectors and at some point I really had
like almost 600 api's instance is
running and the other thing I wanted to
mention a feature that I particularly
like so when you look at the services so
the versions sorry I have two versions
for my application here so this is the
normal version but I also have a grey
version so if I want to do some a/b
testing to see if users prefer a grey
background instead of white I can easily
do here in the console I can easily do
speed traffic at random I want to add a
new version and for example I want this
new the grey version to get
a bit of traffic some updating those
settings so you can do it with a g-cloud
command line and wine seal once in a
while you should see a different
background white white white gray at
some point yeah gray at some point so
it's fairly easy to do a traffic
splitting for a be tasting can really
really sees green blue deployments and
so on alright that's it let's switch
back to the slides Thank You Guillaume
so let's recap quickly what we've seen
we've seen an application deployed
across cloud functions and App Engine
with multiple functions written in Java
Script with node and one applic a pidgin
app using multiple services all of this
including idiomatic language runtime
such as node obviously for the functions
Java 8 and go for the admin part we've
used multiple GCP services again both
functions and App Engine the reason you
want to use those services is that
you're able to access the power of GCP
you used the vision API which is one of
the main pieces that gets you oldest
tags but we've used a number of
additional services as well the things
that we haven't shown too much but we
have a reference to another talks that
we encourage you to go to is how SAG
driver aggregates all the logs from all
the parts of your application and
provides you with very interesting
information both for developing and for
managing the application you know giving
away responsibility of scaling the
application doesn't mean giving away all
the ops job and and and keeping you from
seeing what's really happening quite the
opposite in fact and of course this was
fully serviced no server was harmed in
this demo now what you've seen is that
we're able to take your artifacts
whether they come in the form of a
function a collection of functions an
app with one or multiple modules and
that's that's great and we do this and
we take those artifacts and we ought to
scale them and you know it's a paper use
model now increasingly people are
packaging their code
into containers for various reasons so
what if we were able to offer you the
developer the choice of taking not just
functions or apps as deployment units
but also containers and still offer that
service operational model with Auto
scale beta scalability and pay-per-use
so here are a couple of upcoming options
that we're excited to share with you and
that have been that we're announced and
covered this morning in the keynote the
first one is called service containers
imagine we have containers that are
stateless that comply to some
request/response signature the promise
here of service containers is to offer
that auto scalability health checks for
applications packaged in those
containers with you know arbitrary
libraries
so imagine a random or any docker file
with any base image an arbitrary set of
libraries or language runtime be able to
deploy this with a command that you are
familiar with g-cloud functions deploy
and simply adding this option of
pointing to that particular container
that again it needs to be stateless well
if you do that our job will be to
provide you that serverless environment
where we auto scale and do all the
health checks and all the monitoring
that is required no servers and still
pay only while the code runs I should
like to sign off for the EAP that is
coming before the end of this year
GTO slash serverless containers and this
is g-cloud functions deploy now a second
option is the service add-on for gke and
this was also discussed this morning so
whether we're talking GAE
which we know and love in Google cloud
platform or the GAE on pram which was
just announced as well here what we have
is a one-step install technology built
on K native you haven't seen K native
you probably want to look at this as an
open source project that's helping make
those artifacts that you deploy portable
and and in this case we use this and we
built the service add-on for JK on cane
and this what it allows is for you to
deploy it this time with a new artifact
the deploy with not only the container
but also the cluster the kubernetes
cluster whether it's on Prem or jke that
you would like to target and the reason
we'd like to to do this or to offer this
as an option as if you were to reuse an
infrastructure that you already have
that you already know or maybe you would
like to have some custom VM sizes in
that JK cluster or GPUs so with all
those reasons we have yet another option
for you to deploy service workloads this
time on jke so it's time to scale down
to zero yeah Guillaume I want to thank
you but we need thankfully to conclude
yeah so whenever you've got small units
of code that you need in an even driven
approach functions are definitely a
great fit for a bigger business logic
long running web apps web api or
backends App Engine is really awesome
and scales like you know snapchat style
and service add-on for when you need
more portability more control on where
you were actually running or if you need
special resources like GPUs or that kind
of stuff so it's up to you and you can
mix everything together there are some
more sessions happening tomorrow yeah so
thanks again for your attention and see
you soon thank you
[Music]